seminarista y estudiante universitario
llamado Jonathan Daniels, procedente de Cambridge, en Massachussets.
Ambos
éramos parte de una generación de jóvenes idealistas
cuya vida era encendida
por la llama de la libertad
que la gente común negra propagaba por toda la nación
hasta alcanzar el Sur.
Nos desplazamos al condado de Lowndes
para trabajar en el movimiento.
Era un movimiento pacífico
para redimir las almas de EE. UU.
Creemos que todos,
blancos y negros,
la gente del Sur
podía encontrar el camino redentor
para liberarse del yugo del racismo
que los había dominado durante más de 400 años.
Un caluroso día de verano de agosto,
Jonathan y yo participamos en una manifestación
de jóvenes negros del lugar
que protestaban contra la explotación
de los aparceros negros
por parte de los ricos terratenientes que les engañaban con el dinero.
Decidimos manifestarnos con ellos.
La mañana de la manifestación,
nos encontramos con una turba de hombres blancos que aullaban
con bates de béisbol, escopetas
y cualquier otra arma que puedan imaginar.
Y amenazaban con matarnos.
El sheriff, al ver el peligro que corríamos,
nos arrestó y nos metió en un camión de la basura
para llevarnos a la cárcel local,
donde nos encerraron en celdas
en las condiciones más inhumanas que se puedan imaginar.
Los carceleros nos amenazaban
con hacernos beber agua de los retretes.
Finalmente nos liberaron al sexto día
sin ninguna información ni aviso previo.
Como caído del cielo,
éramos libres para irnos.
Supimos que eso era una señal peligrosa
ya que también habían obligado a salir de la cárcel a Goodman, Schwerner y Chaney
y fueron asesinados porque nadie sabía qué les había ocurrido.
Así, a pesar de nuestra voraz resistencia,
el sheriff nos obligó a abandonar la cárcel,
y por supuesto, nadie nos esperaba.
Hacía calor,
era uno de esos días sureños
en los que podían sentir en el cemento...
el vapor emanando del cemento.
Y nuestro grupo de unas 14 personas
eligió a Jonathan Daniels,
al Padre Morrisroe, recién llegado al condado,
a Joyce Bailey, una joven local de 17 años
y a mí para ir a comprar bebidas.
Al llegar a la puerta,
un hombre blanco estaba bajo el marco con una escopeta
y gritó: "¡Te voy a volar los sesos, puta!"
Antes de que pudiese reaccionar,
antes de entender qué ocurría,
Jonathan tiró de mi blusa a propósito
y caí de espaldas, creyéndome muerta.
En ese instante, al levantar la mirada,
Jonathan Daniels estaba en la línea de fuego,
recibió el balazo
y me salvó la vida.
Quedé tan traumatizada
y paralizada por lo ocurrido,
que Tom Coleman, deliberadamente
y con mala fe,
hubiese asesinado a mi amado amigo y colega,
Jonathan Myrick Daniels.
Ese día,
que fue uno de los más importantes de mi vida,
vi tanto el amor como el odio
procedentes de dos hombres blancos muy distintos
que representaban lo mejor y lo peor de EE.UU.
Tan grande era mi dolor
por haber visto a Tom Coleman matar a Jonathan ante mis ojos
que me volví silenciosa
y no hablé
durante seis meses.
Finalmente, aprendí a tocar esa herida interior
al hacerme mayor,
y empecé a hablar sobre el movimiento de liberación sureño
y a conectar mis relatos
con los de otros colegas y luchadores por la libertad
quienes como yo, se habían enfrentado al trauma mortal del racismo,
habían perdido amigos por el camino
y habían sido apaleados y encarcelados.
Han pasado 50 años.
Muchos fueron apalizados y encarcelados.
Otros fueron asesinados como Jonathan Daniels.
Y a pesar de eso, como nación estamos todavía
hundidos
en el lodazal del racismo.
Allá donde voy del país,
veo y oigo el dolor.
Y pregunto a la gente,
"Dime, ¿dónde duele?"
¿Ven y oyen el dolor
que yo veo y siento?
Siento y veo el dolor de los negros e hispanos
que cada día sufren la carga viciosa del racismo
y cada día se ven despojados de sus derechos civiles y humanos.
Y la gente que lo hace se vale de mitos y estereotipos
para justificarlo.
Allá donde voy
veo y oigo a mujeres
que claman contra...
que claman contra los hombres que invaden nuestros cuerpos.
Los mismos que se dan la vuelta,
los mismos que promueven el racismo
y se dan la vuelta y roban nuestro trabajo y nos pagan salarios desiguales.
Oigo y siento el dolor de los hombres blancos
por la traición de los propios hombres blancos poderosos
que afirman que su color de piel
es su pasaje a una buena vida y al poder,
sólo para descubrir que
a medida que se estrecha el círculo de blancura,
sus pasajes han caducado
y ya no son de primera clase.
Ahora que hemos experimentado el dolor,
debemos preguntarnos,
"¿Dónde duele?
y ¿cuál es la causa de dolor?"
Propongo que observemos
en profundidad la cultura de la blancura.
Es el río que ahoga todas nuestras identidades
y nos ahoga en una uniformidad falsa para mantener el status quo.
Observen todos que he dicho la cultura de la blancura
y no la gente blanca.
Porque según mi teoría,
el problema no son los blancos.
Es la cultura de la blancura.
Y con cultura de la blancura
me refiero al grupo de creencias sistemático y organizado,
a valores, conocimiento canónico e incluso religión,
que mantiene una estructura de poder jerárquica y supremacista
basada en el color de la piel en contra de la gente de color.
Es una cultura
donde los blancos se consideran miembros amigables y necesarios
mientras que la gente de color, especialmente los negros,
se consideran peligrosos
y extraños amenazadores,
que suponen un peligro presente y real
para la seguridad y la eficacia
de la cultura de la blancura.
Escúchenme y vean si pueden imaginar
la cultura de la blancura como un proceso deshumanizador
que deshace
nuestras múltiples identidades entrelazadas
como la raza, la clase, el género y la sexualidad.
De manera...
de manera que se mantiene la unidad para el poder.
Creo, por que lo sé,
que la cultura de la blancura
es una construcción social.
Todos nosotros, del nacimiento a la muerte,
socializamos en esta cultura.
Y también marca a la gente de color.
Y hace que la gente de color, igual que los blancos,
voten en contra de nuestros intereses.
Algunos se preguntarán...
y mis alumnos siempre comentan que las tareas que mando son difíciles,
algunos se preguntarán, con toda la razón,
"¿Cómo arreglamos esto?
Parece todo tan omnipotente y abrumador."
Creo que debemos solucionarlo,
porque no podemos humanizar el futuro
si seguimos siendo cómplices
de la cultura de la blancura.
Todos debemos conectar con nuestro verdadero yo,
con nuestro yo étnico verdadero.
Y debemos conectar con los otros aspectos de nuestra identidad.
Y debemos escapar de las construcciones
de la blancura, la morenez y la negrura
para convertirnos en quien somos al máximo.
¿Cómo lo lograremos?
Creo que podemos hacerlo a través de la narrativa colectiva.
las narrativas colectivas deben incluir nuestras historias personales,
las artes,
reflexiones espirituales,
literatura,
y sí, también percusión.
(Risas)
Debe ser una narrativa colectiva,
porque las historias individuales sólo crean un paradigma
en el que contraponemos una historia contra otra.
Los diferentes modelos de lo que he hablado hoy
creo que son esenciales para ofrecernos un camino
para salir del cenagal del racismo.
Quiero hablar sobre otro modelo muy importante.
Se trata de la redención.
Creo que los movimientos para la justicia social
deben ser redentores en vez de punitivos.
Y sí, creo que
debemos ofrecer la posibilidad de redención para todos.
Y debemos estar dispuestos,
a pesar del lenguaje cáustico
que pueda venir precisamente de los opresores,
pienso que debemos escucharles
y tratar de averiguar dónde les duele.
Creo que debemos hacerlo
porque nuestra redención está ligada a la suya,
y no seremos libres
hasta que todos estemos redimidos de una ira sin redención.
El desafío no es fácil.
Y en una sociedad tecnológica, resulta aún más complejo,
porque con frecuencia usamos la tecnología
para perpetuar los valores del racismo que permitimos diariamente.
Usamos la tecnología para acosar,
para perpetuar el discurso del odio
y degradar la humanidad ajena.
Por eso creo que, si vamos a humanizar el futuro,
debemos diseñar maneras de usar la tecnología
no para degradarnos, sino para edificarnos
y poder vivir al máximo de nuestras capacidades.
Y opino que la tecnología
debe proporcionarnos horizontes más amplios
para poder conectar con los demás
e ir más allá de nuestro espacio compartimentado.
Creo
que podemos lograrlo si centramos la mente
y las esperanzas en la recompensa.
la pregunta que nos planteamos hoy
es muy seria.
Es: "¿Quieren curarse?"
"¿Quieren curarse?"
¿Quieren sentirse completos y vivir todas sus identidades?
¿O prefieren continuar canibalizando sus múltiples identidades
y privilegiar a una por encima de las demás?
¿Quieren formar parte de la larga lista
de generaciones de personas
que creyeron en la promesa de EE.UU.
y tuvieron la fe para construir la democracia?
¿Quieren vivir al máximo de su pontencial?
Yo sí, desde luego.
Y creo que Uds. también.
Déjenme decirles seriamente
que creo en Uds.
Y a pesar de todo,
todavía creo en EE.UU.
Espero que el regalo que les he hecho esta noche,
que he compartido con Uds.
proporcione caminos redentores
para que puedan reclamar la plenitud de su identidad
y convertirse en participantes principales
de la humanización del futuro no sólo para Uds.,
si no también para nuestra democracia.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)